hey guys my name is Jeff today it is the
11th of April and you're tuned into
gamespot niche tribe masters the
developers of the grid dirt and the f1
series have hired driveclub debs after
the closure of evolution studios the
publisher wrote on its blog codemasters
will be expanding its portfolio of
studios to include the highly respected
and very talented team from evolution
studios sony announced their plans to
close evolution on march 22 which would
put many of the developers out of work
codemasters added this expansion will
not only see us gained a wealth of
racing expertise and skill but it'll
take codemasters to the next level as
the world's largest recent focused games
company Sony said that the restructure
will allow them to focus on quote other
studios that already have exciting new
projects in development evolutions
portfolio includes driveclub as well as
the most storm and WRC series
codemasters has been making racing games
since 1986 EA and respawn entertainment
have released the first teaser trailer
for titanfall to which they intend to
fully reveal in coming months the video
features a voiceover discussing the
risks of being a hero while a Titan
approaches a sort of drop pod which
bears the name James Kalin the teaser
ends by showing that the full reveal
will come on jun 12 the date of EA's pre
III briefing on top of that to the game
is going to come to ps4 as well as pc
and xbox one this time around the
divisions big update and first incursion
mission land tomorrow and Ubisoft have
released a trailer to show it all up the
update is also adding loop trading play
reporting more gear special gear set and
it will hopefully make the daily
missions actually work again Ubisoft has
addressed that a bug resulted in the
disappearance of daily missions after
which they explained on Twitter please
note for the issue with daily hard and
challenging wish
will be fixed with the update deployed
on April 12 Ubisoft also released an
info graphic showing us exactly how
division players like to play for
example forty-three percent of play time
is spent in court the most popular
primary weapon is the classic AK 47
players have done 150 million jumping
jacks and most of you like me prefer to
dressing the training hoodie for the
post-apocalypse let me know down in that
comment section with your keen for the
division update and be sure I had to
gain sparkle we've got stories
uncatchable floor and rust that is
everything I help you today let me down
in that comment section what mattered to
you and I will see you again tomorrow